In this section of our course, we will begin by learning how to access the MetaHuman creator
using Quixel Bridge.
And from there, we will dive into the MetaHuman creator and explore all of its tools.
Let us begin our journey by first learning how to access the MetaHuman creator using
the Unreal Engine 5 Quixel Bridge integration, and then look at some of the additional assets
we can download with the Quixel Bridge standalone application.
So let's jump into Unreal Engine and go through the steps.
To access MetaHumans directly in Unreal Engine, in the main viewport, go to the Get Content
panel and select Quixel Bridge.
With Quixel Bridge open, ensure you sign in using your Epic Games account.
On the top right, go to Preferences and ensure you have a Megascans folder path assigned.
Now, select the MetaHuman's option in the Quixel Bridge menu.
Then select a preset MetaHuman.
And then on the right hand side, over here, select Start MetaHuman creator.
The browser will open and prompt you to select the engine version you wish to work with.
And from here, select Launch MetaHuman creator.
Now before we move on, let's do a quick review of the steps we just covered.
To access MetaHumans directly in Unreal Engine, use the Get Content panel to access Quixel Bridge.
Sign in using your Epic Games account and inside of Preferences ensure you have a Megascans folder assigned.
From there, select the MetaHuman's option in the Quixel Bridge menu.
Select a preset and then select Start MetaHuman creator.
Once the browser opens, select the engine version you are working in and then launch the MetaHuman creator.
Now let's take a look at using the Quixel Bridge standalone application for use with MetaHumans.
The Quixel Bridge standalone applications allows for Maya and Zebra scopes to be downloaded for DNA files to be accessed and for exporting MetaHumans to Unreal Engine 4.27.
Begin by going to the web browser link for Quixel Bridge and sign in with your Epic Games account.
From there, download and install the application.
The Quixel Bridge plugin will be located in the Epic Games launcher and should automatically install along with the latest versions of the engine.
Now let's jump into the Quixel Bridge standalone application and take a look at some of our options.
Inside of the Quixel Bridge standalone application, navigate to the Quixel Bridge menu on the top left
and select the MetaHuman's option.
Then select MetaHuman presets for the engine version you are using, which in our case will be the MetaHuman presets for Unreal Engine 5.
By selecting any MetaHuman preset, you can access the MetaHuman creator by selecting Start MetaHuman creator over here on the right.
You can download and export MetaHuman presets or ones you've created to Autodesk Maya.
To do this with a MetaHuman selected, go to the bottom right and over here if you click here next to the resolution option, you can select the download or export settings.
We are going to select the download settings first.
In the download settings, go to models and make sure the download option for MetaHuman is set to source assets.
If you are using Unreal Engine 4.27, set it to UAsset and SourceAsset.
Now let's go back and select export settings.
In the export target tab, change the export target to Autodesk Maya and install the Maya plugin if it is not already installed.
Upon opening up Autodesk Maya, the MS plugin pop-up will appear, which means the plugin has been successfully installed.
The next step is to download a MetaHuman by going to the bottom right corner and selecting download.
A green check mark will appear indicating that the download process is complete.
Now if you want to export this to Autodesk Maya, with the blank Maya scene open, you can select export.
Another thing you can do is access the MetaHuman DNA and Maya Source Assets files by going to the vertical ellipsis right below the thumbnail and select go to files.
This will open up the location of the downloaded assets in your Megascans folder.
Now let's do a quick review of everything we've just covered.
We have just gone over how to select MetaHuman presets for Unreal Engine 5 inside of the Quixel Bridge standalone application.
We've also covered that we need to change the download settings to SourceAssets and the export target to Autodesk Maya
along with installing the Maya plugin.
The MS plugin pop-up icon will appear in Maya ensuring the plugin is installed.
We've also learned how we can locate and access our downloaded assets in our Megascans folder such as our MetaHuman DNA and Maya Source files.
Now that we have covered this information, let's dive into the MetaHuman creator.